my question's from mike when you were
djing what kind of events did you do and
what were those bangers that you dropped
bro
thanks for taking my question i
appreciate it were you a disc jockey i
was yeah i was a professional dj for
15 years yeah really yeah like like a
nightclub dj yeah
like did you also do like weddings and
dances nah nothing like come on
i swear to god no so so i was obsessed
with martial arts
and then i went i was walking home from
one of the uh
wild dude i was walking off from one of
the shitty dead-end jobs that i had
yeah and i went popped into my friend's
house and he had a set of turntables and
records and stuff and we were into dance
music and i just thought that was the
coolest stuff
[ __ ] i've ever seen in my life and like
what kind of music was it it was like
you know house music yeah house music
techno stuff like that
and we were all heavy heavy into it up
there you know and uh
yeah i bought a set of decks and i just
i'm kind of all or nothing
i'm very obsessive i'm doing something i
just submerge myself into that
and uh that's what i did and i i i gave
it martial arts and i wanted to be a dj
yeah and you know i was i was doing all
right you know dj mikey b that was my
name
uh now what were some like now would you
play a couple of tracks to kind of get
people to like you know i i don't know i
don't know but
but if you saw a little bit of love
going on in the distance would you drop
on a certain track no
the place where i dj bro they they they
were hardcore like rave spots you know
the main song did you have mosh pitting
and stuff you ever seen it's not marsh
but it's just
people dancing the [ __ ] asses off you
know what i mean but uh so i was doing
that for a long time and then i kind of
came to the realization
that i'm not gonna make it big time i'm
not gonna be one of these guys getting
20 30 000 for a set you know what i mean
yeah i i was doing i was just about
making enough money to live but it was
fun
fortunately when i decided i wanted to
be a fighter
i was able to train all week and dj at
the weekend
and just scrape by enough money to be
able to pay the bills and
and not get the house repossessed and
all that type of stuff yeah until
fighting started making money you know
what i mean but uh
and were you were you fighting like a
beat in the beginning i pitched you like
dun dun
dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun like
punching and stuff
no no no nobody knew nobody knew like
that that i was like this one club i dj
that was like
it was it was a very well respected
dance club but the place was it was
sketchy man it was like
you guys would like someone straight up
a guy richie movie because it was an
all-nighter so all the doormen would
finish
work at two but then they'd go to
monroe's afterwards to party so it was
just full of doormen and gangsters and
drug dealers and all that kind of
[ __ ] the [ __ ] that went on that club
will make your head spin i've
i've seen guys come in with samurai
swords and hack guys up i meant i i i
swear to god
i was standing by the front entrance
chatting away that's a career and
everyone just started [ __ ] stampeding
out the club and i'm like
what is going on and then i look and i
see a guy with a balaclava and
oh just storming out the club like that
i'm like holy [ __ ]
and he just hacked someone up on the
dance floor did he play his tab though
they let him in through the fire exit
with the samurai sword
yeah and then another time yeah a
terrible [ __ ] well he probably knew the
doorman
but another time because i used to do
two sets i do like a set from like two
till three yeah and then another set
from like six to seven a.m
so i'd have a few hours in between and
we just hang out do whatever
and i went back to do my second set yeah
and uh
my records have been stolen back then i
was like they were my pride and joy
right yeah because a lot of the music
was hard to get you know very rare and
whatever
and they were my babies my records man
they've been [ __ ] stolen but as i
said i
i used to keep myself to myself and
people didn't know that i was a fighter
or whatever do you know what i mean
[ __ ] just take my beats records [ __ ]
him it's a [ __ ]
he took my records and i was fuming so i
went outside onto the car park
and i was going up to every car i'm like
yo open your trunk
open your boot that's what i'm caught in
england open your boot i want to check
and that what first of my records have
been stolen open your [ __ ] boot
they'd open it up and say okay
not there sorry pal i had to check next
card so
i went through a few i went through a
few cars i get to this one car
that's it the guy's sitting there
smoking a joint oh he's gone i'm like
he's guilty i said yo guilty open the
door uh
open the boot is that can't do that i
said dude listen my [ __ ] records have
been stolen all right i just want to
check your boot
open the boot he's like i can't do that
i said well now you've got to [ __ ] do
it it goes
all right relax he said i'll open my
boot he said but when you see what's in
there
you got to shut the [ __ ] up i know what
it was i said all right was it a tiger
that's all right whatever
open the [ __ ] booty [ __ ] but he
gets up he opens the boot
there's a [ __ ] guy in there tied up
with the gag on
ankles tied with it
i'm like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] he slams it down
and goes
i haven't got your [ __ ] records bro
i'm like okay
i guess you haven't moving on so if you
were that guy in that boot
my bad who was that guy he was a guy
i don't know but i didn't want any part
of that [ __ ] i'm like [ __ ] those records
take him you're good i i never liked him
anyway
was it pretty awesome man that must have
been awesome huh no it wasn't
the guy looked scared or like they were
playing hide and go seek i don't know
how to go see as i say
you know did it look like a sexual thing
or they were just like wasn't it
maybe it was you know what i like to
think it was a sexual yeah
i like to think it was it's okay that's
just how they got off yeah you know or
just because i
i threw in an extra dynamic like oh
we've got a crazy skid head once his
record's back this is role-playing
i've never seen this before it's like
get him in get in the trunk
give it a shot it's good
oh [ __ ] so yeah wow i never had it i
never had any uh no
no no and that's one of many
unfortunately that's why i had to get
out of that life
you know oh yeah it doesn't it you know
two years later it's you in the trunk or
two in the driver's seat
probably one or the other exactly you
know so uh so yeah
you know i had to make a better life for
myself yeah which is again
what i did i'm just sitting on your
front porch
wondering how could i be so far from my
home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been
blown